elisabeth kübler ross était une
psychiatre helvético américaine
elisabeth kübler-ross était sans doute
la plus grande référence mondiale en
termes de thanatologie alors la
thanatologie pour ceux qui ne savent pas
ce que c'est c'est tout simplement la
science de la mort ou plus exactement
l'étude de la mort ce n'est pas tu sur
l'être humain aussi bien table physique
que psychique comme leurs grosses tout
au long de ces expériences a pu
rencontrer des milliers de personnes
quitter en fin de vie et discuter avec
nous et ces personnes là finalement où
une grande majorité faisait ressortir un
certain nombre de thèmes récurrents qui
revenait dans cette perspective de la
fin de vie deux en particulier le
premier c'était des regrets formulés par
rapport à une rupture un d'éloignement
avec une personne chère un ami un proche
pour des raisons qui finalement toujours
dans cette perspective de la prochaine
assemblée des réseaux au fond bien
futile et le deuxième terme 7 et des
regrets exprimés
non pas sur ce que ces personnages aient
pu faire non pas sur les erreurs qu'elle
n'avait plus communes commettre mais
bien au contraire surtout ce qu'elle
n'avait pas fait toutes les fois qu'elle
n'avait pas osé ou tenter de faire des
choses
j'aurais tellement aimé faire telle ou
telle chose on est là je crois au coeur
même de ce qu'une ruine y aujourd'hui
l'audace et l'innovation
car si je pense qu'on sera tous d'accord
pour dire que l'audace en tant que telle
ne peut pas être suffisante pour
garantir l'innovation
cependant il ne peut pas y avoir
d'innovation pour cible s'il n'y a pas
une part d'audace sinon vous hante pas
en capacité de penser de vous projeter
et 2
réfléchir de manière différente
finalement de penser au delà de ce que
le commun des mortels peut penser penser
l'impensable pour toucher l'impossible
mark twain ghz et il ne savait pas que
c'était impossible alors ils l'ont fait
et c'est clairement ce qui vous attend
l'enjeu il est là il est en capacité
d'inventer ce que d'autres n'ont même
pas pensé
donc il s'agit simplement d'être en
capacité de se réinventer soi-même de
réinventer sa manière de penser sa
manière d'être pour inspirer à un moment
donné être en capacité d'innover et ça
passe à travers trois phases bien
spécifiques qui sont croire créer et
calibré alors croire tout d'abord
comment vous évidemment croire à vos
propres capacités à ce que vous pouvez
faire au jour le jour
avoir confiance en vous sauf que la
confiance est quelque chose qui ne se
mesurent pas la confiance est une notion
absolue si je demande à mon meilleur ami
par exemple si la confiance à moi et
qu'il veut répondre un peu
et bien c'est à dire tout simplement
qu'il n'a pas confiance en moi
on a donc là une notion qui ne peut pas
être quantifiées nous sommes obligés
d'aller au delà nous sommes obligé de
parier sur la confiance
nous sommes obligés tout simplement de
croire en nos capacités et avoir cette
confiance en soi suppose être en
capacité
et bien tout simplement de mettre nos
protecteurs de d'arrêter de d'autres sa
beauté et de
capacité finalement de s'éloigner de ce
qu'on appelle des croyances limitantes
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez ainsi 80 c'est
tout simplement ce prisme qu'il existe
entre nous et le monde qui nous entoure
c'est quelque chose qui ne dépendent pas
de nous qui vous a été transmis
y compris de manière totalement
inconsciente par nos parents par nos
enseignants par nos amis nos relations y
compris par nos propres expériences
bonnes ou mauvaises d'ailleurs et qui
ont fait que finalement petit à petit
nous avons créé les schémas que l'on
appelle donc ses fameuses croyances
limitantes alors quelques exemples
peut-être à vous donner
il s'agit de croyances qui romprait avec
vous même ce sont des croyances du style
jamais je serai capable différence
je suis trop petit trop vieux pour
entreprendre trop jeune je n'ai jamais
eu de chance ou bien encore par exemple
j'ai toujours eu des problèmes avec les
matins et puis à les croyances et qui
sont pas dire nous mêmes mais qui sont
liées au monde qui nous entoure
ou plus exactement à la façon dont nous
voyons le monde qui nous entoure
ce sont des croyants se distille la vie
est tellement dur ou bien encore à c'est
trop beau pour être vrai ou bien peut
pas tout avoir dans la vie et celle ci
que j'aime particulièrement
il faut trimer pour réussir vous
d'alizée nous sommes ce que nous pensons
en réalité nous sommes ce que nous
croyons m nous agissons très exactement
en fonction de ce que nous croyons être
nos capacités et non pas en fonction de
ce que sont nos capacités réellement
ça veut dire tout simplement qu'à partir
du moment et c'est ainsi que même des
croyances limitantes ou pensons que nous
avons des capacités plus limitée que ce
qu'elles sont en réalité
eh bien ça veut dire que nous agissons
en dessous de ce qu'on de capacités qui
sont nôtres
peut-être avez-vous entendu parler de
l'effet pygmalion du professeur et
professeur robert rosenthal
le professeur aux étals et pour sommité
en psychologie sociale américaine dans
les années 50 et il décida de mener
l'expérience suivante dans une école
défavorisée de san francisco il dit aux
accidents qu'il allait faire passer des
tests aux élèves des classes de cette
école il fit passer effectivement le
test et puis ça veut dire aux
enseignants il choisit de manière
totalement aléatoire totalement au
hasard c'est ou six élèves est présente
à ses élèves aux enseignants leur disant
voilà ce sont les élèves écurie si les
meilleurs tests de toute l'école donc on
peut supposer que ces élèves là vont
avoir une capacité d'apprentissage
exponentielle bien meilleur que
l'ensemble de la classe et puis le
professeur présentable ça nous faisait
partie airs vers la fin de l'année juin
suivant et peut-être certaines trouvent
déjà deviné mais quand le professeur ou
un tel revers en duel il se retrouva
avec ces élèves là qu'il avait désigné
encore une fois de manière totalement au
hasard ont maintenant les élèves qui
avaient réussi les meilleurs résultats
pourquoi
tout simplement parce que le professeur
ou un talent était une éminence une
référence dans son monde
une ces personnes qu'on ne va évidemment
pas questionner donc quand ces élèves
avaient de bons résultats finalement
c'était normal attendu le professeur aux
elle l'avait dit et quand évidemment il
y avait de mauvais résultats et bien de
ces cas là les professeurs du coup nous
questionner pas le presseur orientale
c'est dans leur propre manière de
je suis pas mal fait va falloir que je
tente une autre manière
pire encore avec les autres élèves
l'attitude enseignante conditionner les
autres élèves pour qu'ils aient des
résultats en baisse
si l'un d'eux par exemple faisait tomber
un stylo le professeur hamas n usa voici
ton stylo 1% de voilà ton stylo c'est
pas grave et 99 102 qu'est ce que tu
aimes maladroit quand même et donc qu'on
a là finalement petit à petit une
prophétie qui va se réaliser car voyez
vous et c'est ça qui est extrêmement
puissant dans les croyances
quand notre cerveau est une croyance il
va faire tout pour la valider et croyez
moi il n'y arrive quand pascal dupraz en
mars 2016 et du nommé nouvel entraîneur
du toulouse football club
lors de sa première conférence de presse
il va tenir pourpre ou les mots suivants
va dire j'attends s'il a des gens qui
disent que le toulouse football club à
1% de chance ou un de chasse sur
milliards plus exactement de se
maintenir
un point c'est faux il a une chance sur
deux soit une semaine tiers soit une
semaine kembo et jusqu'à preuve du
contraire le tfc est un leader on
connaît leur style à lui la suite de
l'histoire se réinventer c'est ça être
en capacité de croire que les autres ne
pense pas croit pas dépenser tout
simplement que si ce n'a pas été fait
jusqu'à présent
ça ne veut pas dire nécessairement que
c'est impossible il s'agit simplement
d'être en capacité de construire
l'impossible et on arrive là à notre
deuxième aspect pied créé par
explication disait tout acte
construction passe avant tout par une
phase de déconstruction et dans le cas
qui nous intéresse pour nous mêmes comme
individu déconstruire et être en
capacité de coste de déconstruire tous
les actes que nous faisons mécaniquement
tous les jours je m'explique si je vous
demande par exemple qu'est ce que vous
faites le matin en vous levant
je suis sûr que vous allez m'indiquer
une série de gestes que vous faites
manière automatique
toujours dans le même ordre et sans
vraiment y penser pour ma part je me
lève je vais aux toilettes j'allume la
radio
j'allume la machine à café je me douche
je déjeune je m'habille et je vais
travailler on lâchait matrot et puis
quand j'arrive au travail je fais
exactement les rues jette dans le même
ordre et finalement de schéma en schémas
de patron en pas trop mon activité aux
juments journée va s'écouler sans que je
vous pose réellement la question tous
tout au long de cette journée de la
pertinence de ce que j'ai pu faire
le défi il est d'être en capacité d'être
acteur du changement est donc finalement
de se proposer autre chose et d'être
créatif changé par exemple vos petits
déjeuners
si vous allez travailler aussi vous
allez étudier ne prenez pas toujours les
mêmes volumes transport ne passait pas
toujours par les mêmes endroits
si vous sortez ne sortait pas toujours
au même endroit avec toujours les mêmes
gens n'avaient pas toujours au même
restaurant pour demander toujours les
mêmes plats soyez créatifs aux est assis
à la terrasse d'un café sur le siège de
l'autobus regarder les gens qui sont
autour de vous regardez les imaginer
quelles peuvent être leurs vies leurs
émotions
ce qu'ils pensent comment il interagit
avec les gens réinventer finalement tous
nous avons autour de vous
pour pousser les champs du possible et
encore une fois soyez a ainsi les
acteurs du changement que vous soutenez
peut-être connaissez-vous % d'entre vous
le théorème du singe
des scientifiques ont décidé de réunir
dans un laboratoire une dizaine de chefs
de chimpanzés et puis au milieu de cette
salle ils décidèrent de poser nues le
tableau et puis un tas de bananes
évidemment la première le premier acte
gestes des chimpanzés fille de
s'approcher de la table pour essayer de
manger des bananes
le problème c'est que systématiquement
dès qu'un singe essaie de s'accrocher
il y avait une douche d'eau glacée qui
leur tombait dessus tant et si bien que
rapidement les chimpanzés associèrent le
fait de manger des bananes et le fait de
ceux de recevoir une douche d'eau glacée
et rapidement déclenchées pensée tenter
de monter sur la table et bien les
autres chimpanzés leur servent
copieusement et puis on change un
premier singe qui lui n'avait pas vécu
l'expérience de l'eau glacée et
qu'évidemment voyant la table avec les
bananes s'y précipitent a évidemment ses
congénères commencèrent le frappeur à le
frapper pour tâter si bien que huit même
ceux mis à frapper les autres singes
chimpanzés qui tentaient à d'autres
moments de monter sur la table
et puis on change un deuxième siège et
puis un troisième et tous se confronter
à la même expérience de finalement tenté
de monter sur la table et de recevoir
nous vous les deux bras vers savons que
moment aucun finalement à la fin de
l'expérience n'ai vécu l'expérience
initiale de la douche froide
à ce moment précis c'est le singe pour
me parler je suis sûr que sur leur
demander cela posé la question de savoir
pourquoi il faisait ça leurs réponses
seraient peu ou prou d'écouté je sais
pas on a toujours c'est comme ça je vois
pas ça change
alors osez rozon ne pas être des
chimpanzés ozon ne pas être finalement
imprimant disent simplement va se
limiter à être d'accord avec le fait de
faire exactement ce qui a été fait
jusqu'à présent ça se pose également la
question de pourquoi s'est fait comme ça
et on arrive au 3e point de ma
conférence qui est simplement le fait de
calibrer nous avons nous que nous
faisons car s'il s'agit bien de tenter
il s'agit d'assumer aussi tout
simplement que nous sommes nous devons
être en capacité de mesurer ce que nous
faisons est évidement d'assumer que
c'est bien si nous faisons un certain
nombre de choses ça ne nous garantit pas
aucunement est bien de réussir
nous pouvons aussi nous tromper et non
seulement nous pouvons mais nous devons
l'assumer en tant que terre toute
personne normale qui évidemment se
propose des objectifs mais normalement
peu à un moment donné se trompait pas
nous tromper parce qu'en fait il n'y a
pas d'échec il n'y a que du feedback
il n'y a pas d'échec il est injuste de
l'information que vous allez recevoir
sur les erreurs qui ont été commises
peut-être certains d'entre vous
connaissent et l'expérience de thomas
edison l'inventeur de l'électrique
toumani ellison et fit plus de foot des
milliers d' expérience ratée à vannes
pour l'électrique un un jour d'ailleurs
un des journaliste lui posait la
question et sur iphone vous n'êtes pas
déçu quand même d'avoir une tente des
expériences ratées avant de pouvoir
remonter la pole et un clic et il sonne
répondit simplement en fait je vois pas
les choses comme ça j'ai pour moi
trouver dix mille manières de nos parts
et 21 pour l'électrique
le génie d'ellison réside finalement
quoi et résidant au fait de se rappeler
l'enfant que nous sommes
et pourquoi je dis ça parce qu'un enfant
qui est un ramasseux peut-être le savez
vous tente
en moyenne 1500 à 2000 fois avant les
1500 2000 fois où il tombe avant
d'apprendre à marcher alors on est dans
la dans un processus d'apprentissage ou
ses 2000 échec le chenil ellison il
consiste à comprendre ça il consiste à
comprendre que chaque finalement échec
l'amène petit à petit une réussite que
serait l'histoire de l'humanité des
sciences sans les échecs de fleming qui
a découvert la plaine et céline de nobel
qui a inventé la dynamite ou bien encore
de deux versants qui aimante et le
velcrou ces gens là inventons par ever
ce sont des exemples fantastique de
sérendipité cissé fleming qui rentre
dans ce laboratoire au moment ils voient
que finalement serré france a été
contaminée par son voisin de paillasse
décide de balancer aux ordures rue
papineau rock aucun moment nous sommes
content qu'il a découvert la pénicilline
chaque fois que vous commettez une
erreur
pensant fleming et ses lois auxquelles
nous devons ce que vous faites
à ce moment-là peut-être vous servir à
ce que voulaient construire demain je
vous disais au début de mon intervention
qu'ils avaient perdu leurs os avait
rencontré des milliers de personnes qui
finalement me disais tout simplement les
revenus qu'elle avoue dit qu'il a vu à
part tenter plus je vous dirai
simplement ceux ci l'enjeu il n'est pas
de tenter plus ou moins ce n'est même
pas d'innover il est simplement de vous
dire que si demain ou après demain à la
fin de votre ville joue 7 mai fut longue
et riche possible
les disciples de 15 laurence viennent
vous voir pour vous demander si vous
avez des regrets vous soyez simplement
en capacité de leur dire vous savez voir
bien bon an mal an la vie d'aujourd'hui
celle un peu meilleur celle qui était la
mienne je suis né c'est aussi un peu
grâce à moi
merci